hi i'm priyanka and today i'm going to
illustrate the ways in which
ai powers no code application
development for citizen developers like
you
using google cloud's app sheet let's get
[Music]
started
[Music]
organizations around the globe have a
current set of systems and processes
that are performed
manually but would greatly benefit from
customized digitization
the desire to digitize is often stopped
before it begins due to lack of
resources
to take it a step further it's even
harder to implement beneficial
capabilities like ai
to make your business workflows smarter
and more impactful
but ai can be expensive between overhead
sourcing rare talent and implementing a
new infrastructure
finding a solution that meets all the
needs of your organization can be
challenging
so how do you find a solution that can
help
drive digital transformation with the
goodness of ai
google cloud's no code platform app
sheet is an intelligent platform that
enables
anyone to be both an app creator and
an ai expert no matter their background
what makes this possible a combination
of
baked in machine learning and google's
ai in action
these allow app creators to simplify the
app creation process
by interpreting users intent with the
app sheet editor
make their app more powerful and
efficient engage with your data
and users in new ways what does this
look like exactly
smart assistant behaves like google
assistant inside your app
and customized to your business domain
using natural language
it searches your data based on how the
model is trained
can you show me inspections from last
month
another ai capability is optical
character recognition known as
ocr which extracts data from images
here's an example of that in this
inspection app
we've already done some pre-work by
training our data model
to identify what we should be extracting
we'll start a new entry by clicking on
new inspection and can now
add a new image to this form we'll
upload a new image to the app
and we can now see that the form has
been automatically filled with the data
from the image
[Music]
the takeaway from all this is that you
don't have to be an expert to use the
algorithms that provide these
opportunities
we provide no code interfaces that allow
anyone
the ability to create their custom
machine learning models
for their particular business domain
and because these algorithms are built
on top of google cloud ai features
you get the same powerful machine
learning capabilities that were
traditionally
only available to trained software
engineers without writing any code at
all
whether you're trying to find an
inventory item using smart assistant
in your app or taking pictures of asset
tags in the field
there's countless opportunities for
improving your team's efficiency
with app sheet ready to start building
your apps with ai
get started today by clicking this link
happy app building you